parce que pourrait donner le cahier de
doléances les nouveautés aujourd'hui une
nouvelle remarque reçu par mail qui
serait la dernière du cahier de
doléances de la mairie de belleneuve car
à la surprise générale le calendrier a
été avancé depuis de 20 jours la
préfecture de côte-d'or leur a
communiqué l'information lundi soit deux
jours seulement avant la fin c'était un
petit peu surprenant dont notamment du
fait qu'on avait eu des informations un
petit peu différente la semaine dernière
la semaine précédente par rapport aux
délais bon là l'inquiétude c'était de
savoir informer les habitants pour les
habitants interrogés cette fin
précipitée ne semble pas vraiment les
déranger ça va prendre je n'ai plus un
j'aurais pu y aller des réunions et tout
ça je vous le dis franchement ça change
rien pour vous faire une change rien
pour moi
non non non non je suis pas allé j'y
serai pas plus à l'est le maire de
belleneuve a reçu une dizaine de
doléances qui doivent être envoyées dès
demain à la préfecture de dijon
je sais pas comment ça va se passer
nous on aura fait le travail au niveau
local c'est notre job est donc on
s'occupe de la commune au delà on laisse
faire les personnes compétentes
c'est donc la préfecture de côte-d'or
qui se charge désormais du regroupement
et du suivi des cahiers citoyens les
cayes un citoyen comme toutes les
contributions vont être numérisés
centralisée analysé de telle sorte que
le gouvernement ait à sa disposition
l'ensemble des éléments pour étudier les
propositions qu'il fera après le 15
avril et bien évidemment sur le
département de la côte d'or le préfet
ses collaborateurs font un travail de
l'analyse des problématiques locales
afin que nous puissions dans le cas
échéant apporter des réponses aux
questions qui ont été posées
les habitants peuvent encore aller sur
internet sur la plateforme nationale
pour déposer leurs doléances et ce
jusqu'au 15 mars